foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
listen to this let's listen to it
together and and see what it what it's
about
all right position to your [ __ ] if I
unhinged Trump supporters and this and
that
get yourself full of [ __ ]
I got my hat's off to you you can't you
you you you can't withstand it David
you have my information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
suppression balls they make you like
feel badly so you said to your wife or
you said your husband darling let's go
out to dinner and then we'll come back
we love our president but you know the
polls say he can't win well right now
we're leading in almost everywhere it's
a real we're leading
wet already suppression balls
Red Wave
soaking wet already suppression balls
fighting even shows as his running mate
the most liberal senator in America
Kamala
[Music]
Senator Kamala Harris
Democrat
Kamala
if you have a pre-existing condition
Parkinson's diabetes
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you thank
you for coming for you if you are under
the age of senator
[Music]
[Music]
that is about neglect negligence
and in the midst of this public health
pandemic we have a Donald Trump
he knows the deal about coven he has
been informed
that it can kill people that it is five
times as likely to kill as the flu he
knew it was Airborne he knew it could
harm children
[Music]
[Music]
if you have a pre-existing condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing conditions coming for you
if you are under the age of 26 on your
parents coverage they're coming for you
if you love someone
[Music]
Senator Kamala Harris all right welcome
everybody a lot happening today and we
are going to be talking about some of it
we are monitoring a mass shooting at a
mall in Boise Idaho where as far as we
know right now six people have been
injured including a police officer we
are standing by for more information
Another Day in the United United States
another mass shooting unfortunately at
this point not very surprising for
anybody we also are going to be looking
in detail at this incredible story from
Rolling Stones Hunter Walker not hunt
this is not the the hunter stuff they
were talking about this is a different
Hunter it's a reporter who has put
together a bunch of different pieces to
the puzzle of what happened leading up
to January 6th it's essentially as bad
as anything that we could have imagined
and suspected
that's I mean I don't I don't know how
else to say it we're going to listen to
some of your voicemails I I don't know
about this I was going to save it for
tomorrow but Dave Rubin a cultural
critic and the last real liberal Dave
Rubin has interviewed Lauren bobert one
of the most despicable members of
Congress that there is and she made a
variety of different claims during the
interview
um about how the uh I think it was the
election wasn't constitutional or maybe
vaccines aren't constitutional and Dave
Rubin nodded along the last really the
last great thinker I would say Dave
Rubin
um
she says she's sort of pseudo
homeschooling her kids to avoid vaccine
requirements
maybe we'll do that maybe what we'll do
is if we get to a hundred new members
and twitch Subs we'll do open phones
but at 50 we'll do maybe the Dave Rubin
stuff
it's it's something it really is
something
um what else did I have for you guys I
have actually a whole bunch of other
Clips I've got some mask fiascos I've
got voicemails no unbanned requests I
see people asking about
unban requests
but I actually don't have any today so I
can close that out no big deal let me
say a big thank you as we get going here
to Michael Stanley who just signed up on
my website joinpakman.com very much
appreciate that Michael you are number
one in my book today
uh Pablo Swanson coming in with our
first Super Chat and says Obama yeah
this is a new I've asked our friend
small fuzzy Moss to get me the Obama
clip because I don't have it for my
soundboard but it's one of my new
favorite Clips we found it yesterday
during the squid chess broadcast uh I
found it on a random sound board let me
see if I can find it
again I think it was uh
wait a second where was Obama here it is
Obama
I don't know why that gets me every time
it's just it's just perfect Obama
it's reminiscent of prompt which I do
have here on my soundboard anyway Donald
Trump
Obama then he went Donald Trump yeah
Donald Trump exactly
um so we're hoping to have that soon for
the soundboard
um I do want to also say thanks to Dave
B Jen here has gifted two subscriptions
um liquid ice has uh subscribed via
twitch and Milo Wilde has resubscribed
as well so that's five five plus one is
six carry the three and take the square
root and we are six percent of the way
there
um liquid ice also has a question David
what's your favorite type of cheese and
have you had sharp cheddar on apple pie
I am against pie uh I'm against
essentially
to the extent that an empanada is a hand
pie I will accept it but apple pie
cherry pie blueberry pie I'm against all
of it the only one that I am open to
Obama is
um I do like uh like a sweet potato
um pie I guess of sorts
um but no pie is not for me I've had
sharp cheddar and in terms of my
favorite type of cheese let me I'm going
to tell you guys about it about a cheese
here let me let me see here
this is like a great great cheese
this is a classic
this actually may get me canceled only
because
you people we could even put it to a
vote oh 32 dollars a pound I would never
pay that for it but I know that this is
about to be extremely uh an extremely
pompous moment
this is one of my favorite cheeses right
here this is the breuse de argental
it has this orange rind
it is something else
it is something else
uh what's a half pound go for do they do
they increase it no you they don't
increase the price per pound on that
this is a tremendous cheese
um a lot of Jasper Hill cheeses are very
good but this is one where it's like
it's such an elitist cheese but it is
really really good
um sometimes Whole Foods has it it's a
really it's a tremendous cheese
I think I just lost 12 members because
of that unfortunately Dave B did just
gift two more though I appreciate that
putting this that us at eight and
um thank you to Desiree Delong for
signing up at joinpakman.com with
today's coupon code sinks and showers
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers also thanks to Amber Castellano
for signing up at joinpakman.com kicking
us right to 10. so here's the deal for
today I have so much to go through so
there's not going to be any kind of
dearth of material
but I have said if we get to 50 I'll do
the Dave Rubin Lauren bobert interview
Clips they are really wild and then if
we get to a hundred we'll just open
phone lines so many many different uh
and exciting things going on uh today a
couple other real quick super chats
Daniel says the David packman
Correctional Facility I don't even know
what that means oh I guess because I'm
wearing my orange shirt and Josh Cisco
says what do you think about Andrew
Yang's forward party well I am not going
to prejudge it because I uh Andrew sent
me the book he is scheduled to be on
this program this is a heretofore
unannounced interview alert okay hold on
do I have my alert
oh God where is it
now I'm uh
hold on
ah I had my I had my soundboard
here it is
breaking news wait that that wasn't it
hold on a second I had one
I guess I don't have it
okay anyway this has not been
this has not been announced previously
but Andrew Yang will be the guest on
this program on
now let's see I need to figure out when
we're airing it I believe it will be
Monday November 22nd Andrew Yang will be
here and he will be here to answer
questions about the forward party and
then we will figure it all out together
all right so that is um that is
happening
thanks to the up high o answer and Ma
Duke for the twitch Subs appreciate that
guys very much
um yeah so I'll talk about the the
forward party once I know more about it
and once we have Andrew Yang here
to talk about it why not all right let's
get right into this breaking news this
is an incredible story I've done a
condensed sort of analysis of this on
the YouTube channel
uh but let's go this is just incredible
and I'm not going to give you guys the
whole lead up to it because hold on why
are there ads I thought I was blocking
ads here weird I'm not going to give you
the full
backstory you guys know about the riots
and we know you know what we suspected
okay here we go exclusive the January 6
protest organizers say they participated
in dozens of planning meetings with
members of Congress and White House
staff two sources are communicating with
house investigators and detailed a
stunning series of allegations to
Rolling Stone including a promise of a
blanket pardon from the Oval Office this
is Hunter Walker
extraordinary work by Hunter Walker all
right uh oh hold on a second what's
going on
do I have to block ads or open ads to
get the whole article here we go okay
good oh it's not even here I did not re
I am not a rolling stone subscriber oh
my God
let's see what about an incognito window
could that help us
oh my God now there's all sorts of
things popping up
Dear God
okay good now we've got it now we've got
it as the house investigation into the
January 6th attack heats up some of the
planners of the pro-trump rallies that
took place in DC have begun
communicating with Congressional
investigators and sharing new
information about what happened when the
former president supporters stormed the
capital two of these people have spoken
to Rolling Stone extensively in recent
weeks and detailed explosive allegations
that multiple members of Congress were
intimately involved in planning both
Trump's efforts to overturn the election
loss and the January 6th events that
turned violent so surprising no it's
what we suspected all along but now we
have information about it
Rolling Stone separately confirmed a
third person involved in the main
January 6th riot in DC has communicated
with the committee this is the first
report that the commit committee is
hearing major new allegations from
potential cooperating Witnesses while
there have been prior indications that
members of Congress were involved this
is also the first account detailing
their purported role and its scope the
two sources also claim they interacted
with members of Trump's team including
Mark Meadows who was Trump's Chief of
Staff who they describe as having had an
opportunity to prevent the violence okay
it's already crazy but let's look at the
details two sources both of whom have
been granted anonymity due to the
ongoing investigation
describe participating in quote dozens
of planning meetings planning briefings
ahead of that day when Trump supporters
broke into the capital as his election
lost to Biden was being certified here
we go I remember Marjorie Taylor green
specifically the organizer says I
remember talking to probably close to a
dozen other members at one point or
another or their staffs
um
okay for the sake of clarity we're gonna
call one of our sources rally organizer
this is an explanation and the other as
planner both sources were involved in
organizing the main event
uh January 6th Trump spoke at the rally
encouraged people to go to the Capitol
these two sources also helped plan a
series of demonstrations that took place
in multiple states around the country
this was very well organized
between the election and the storming of
the capital according to these sources
multiple people associated with the
March for Trump and stop the steal
events that took place during this
period communicated with members of
Congress throughout this process
along with green the conspiratorial
pro-trump Republican from Georgia who
took office earlier this year the pair
both say the members who participated or
had top staffers join included Paul
gozar absolute radical lunatic
Republican Lauren bobert may be the
dumbest person in Congress maybe close
maybe the dumbest
Congressman Mo Brooks
Congressman Madison cawthorne also up
there competing with Lauren bober
Congressman Andy Biggs and Congressman
Louis Gomer who was a judge if you can
believe it the organizer says we would
talk to bobert's team cawthorne's team
gozar's team like back to back to back
to back
okay
gozar this this is like now we've got to
start going you know
gozar who has been one of the most
prominent Defenders of the rioters
allegedly took things a step further
both sources say he dangled the
possibility of a blanket pardon in an
unrelated ongoing investigation to
encourage them to plan protests the
organizer says our impression was it was
a done deal the pardon that he'd spoken
to the president about it in the oval in
a meeting about Pardons and that our
names came up they were working on
submitting the paperwork and getting
members of the House Freedom caucus to
sign on as a show of support that would
probably be against the law from the
legal opinions I've read so far
uh okay let's continue
the organizer claims the pair received
several assurances about the blanket
pardon from gozar I was just going over
the List's Pardons and we wanted to tell
you guys how much we appreciate all the
hard work you've been doing goes are set
according to the organizer the rally
planner describes the pardon as being
offered while encouraging the staging of
protests against the election while the
organizer says they did not get involved
in planning the rallies solely due to
the pardon they were upset It ultimately
did not materialize I would have done it
either way with or without the pardons
the organizer says I do truly believe in
this country but to use something like
that and put that out on the table when
someone is so desperate it's really not
good business it also may be against the
law and it's certainly immoral
gozar's office didn't respond to
requests for comment that is not a
denial
gozar's office did not respond to
requests for comment wow
wow Rolling Stone has separately
obtained documentary evidence that both
sources were in contact with gozar and
bobert on January 6. we are not
describing the nature of that evidence
to preserve their anonymity okay
um
these specific members of Congress were
involved in the pro-trump activism
around the election and the Electoral
certification on January 6th both Brooks
and cawthorne spoke with Trump at the
ellipse on Jan 6. in his speech at that
event Brooks who was reportedly wearing
body armor that's another thing
why are you wearing body armor if you're
if you're just going to a peaceful event
I mean does he wear body armor all the
time
very bizarre behavior
in his speech at that event Brooks
declared today is the day American
Patriots
start taking down names and kicking ass
goes our green and bobert were all
billed as speakers at the wild protest
which took place January 6.
um Nick Dyer Green's comms director says
she was solely involved in objecting to
the Electoral certification sure of
course they would say that now
spokespeople for the other people have
not responded to uh requests for comment
here's Marjorie Taylor green just as a
reminder
dire further compared Green's efforts to
dispute certification of Biden's Victory
with objections certain Democrats lodged
against Trump's first election
she objected just like Democrats who
have objected to Republican victories
over the years just like in 2017 when
Jim McGovern at all
um tried to prevent Trump's action uh
Trump's election win from being
certified
not exactly
um they weren't giving people tours of
the Capitol right before an attack on
the Capitol by those very people
um
in another indication members of
Congress may have been involved
Ali Alexander who helped organize the
protest declared in a since deleted live
stream broadcast that goes our Brooks
and Biggs helped him formulate the
strategy Alexander said at the time I
remember showing this on a previous live
stream I was the person who came up with
the Jan 6 idea with Congressman gozar Mo
Brooks and Andy Biggs
wow we force schemed up on putting
maximum pressure on Congress while they
were voting so that who we couldn't
Lobby we could change the hearts and the
minds of Republicans who were in that
body
hearing our Roar from the outside it's
com everything about this is Bonkers
Alexander also didn't request a respond
to request for comments
while it was clear members of Congress
played some role
uh the two sources say they can provide
new details about the member's specific
roles I have no problem openly
testifying
so we're going to continue looking at
this it is really really insane and
unfortunately and I know many of you are
asking me this question as as we are
talking about this
it is not clear to me that there will be
repercussions
um AOC called for the expulsion of the
people involved from the house now other
people were saying Ma'am why aren't you
calling for them to go to jail well you
know aoc's a legislator so she can vote
to expel them
um law enforcement needs to look at
whether crimes were committed and there
is reason to believe that crimes were
indeed committed but
will there be consequences
I I wish I could say yes
so far they're really there really
haven't been
um and we'll see in 2022
you know there could be electoral
repercussions in 2022 but a lot of the
people who were involved are running
essentially unopposed in safe Republican
districts
so
what you know that you're probably not
going to see repercussions there either
it is absolutely
insane and everything we suspected seems
to be true and an incredible uh
journalistic undertaking by Hunter
Walker
um check out the article we we've really
hit all the major major points but
Bonkers Bonkers stuff
before we move on to our next element
today I want to say thanks to Jen here
for gifting two subscriptions on Twitch
thanks to Nilla Kitty for the sub J
bomber troikes and Minister putting us
at 18.
um also want to say thank you to Ben
Hanson Kaplan for signing up on my
website joinpakman.com Laura Lynch is a
new member and Mark Ashby just signed up
on my website using the coupon code
sinks and showers we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers that puts
us at 21 so here's what we've got on the
table for today if we get to we're like
almost at 50. if we get to 50 instead of
waiting until tomorrow to do the Dave
Rubin Lauren bobert interview which is
really out of this world I'll do it
today so at 50 I'll do the Dave Rubin
Lauren bobert interview and then if we
get to 100 we'll open phone lines I've
also been asked to get in touch with
Stephen Kenneth Destiny Bonnell II we
haven't checked in with him for a while
I don't know if he's streaming but I
would certainly consider
um checking in with Stephen a little bit
later if uh if people want and if we
actually get through all of the things
that we have planned today a few other
super chats I want to look at my city
has had over 20 homicides this year and
a drive-by at a church yesterday this
isn't what the Second Amendment is for
something needs to be done agreed
should Sanders offer lower drug prices
or Medicare expansion to Joe manchin and
Kristen Cinema Kirsten Cinema give me
one or the other as a negotiation tactic
I'm not sure let me think about that
let me think about that
Masons is David do you believe that this
is damning evidence and that the
Department of Justice will take this
article into consideration God I hope so
God I hope so
in my opinion Yang is an enlightened
Centrist desperate for relevance and the
forward party is a selfish attempt to
normalize the vile politics of the right
that's a hot take and I will ask him
that question when I interview Andrew
Yang on November 22nd we will be airing
that interview
um I'm late to the party what did I miss
well I'm not going to go back you can
just scroll back we have DVR on DVR on
very very strongly on okay let's get to
the next thing which is
um a really bad situation in Idaho we've
had another mass shooting and we're
standing by for some coverage as you can
see here there there may be a press
conference at some point
uh
we're keeping an eye on that and in fact
if anybody in the audience becomes aware
of a press conference related to that
shooting let me know and I'm glad to go
to it but here's what we know so far
six injured at Boise mall shooting
police say
Boise Police said six people injured
including a police officer in a shooting
at the Boise Town Square Mall police say
they're working to notify families of
the victims as they clear them all one
person is in custody police said
officers are working to secure the scene
and people are asked to avoid the area
we don't really know too much else
that's that's the story as of right now
and so we will uh we will monitor
um
and see what uh what if anything comes
of it as we are standing by
um oh uh thanks to lean bean and Ali's
who just signed up via twitch Prime Ali
has a good question what's your favorite
budget cheese for those not part of the
elite okay that's a fair question so
earlier I was asked about cheese and I
indicated this is a fantastic cheese
right here this is the breber roost de
argental incredible cheese
it's an historic cheese I would say
there's another one which sometimes is
on sale very cheap I've seen this for 10
bucks a pound before
it is called telegio
okay telegio this is a very nice cheese
um and often much less expensive it's
semi-soft
washed rind smear ripened Italian cheese
named after the valtelegio it has a thin
crust strong Aroma flavor is
comparatively mild yeah the thing about
telegio is
um
the smell is very very powerful you
could clear a room with this thing okay
but the taste is much less strong
uh that's a great cheese sometimes you
can get it
um for for pretty good deals let's see
what there is if there's a cheese store
let's see telegio
this one doesn't seem to sell it
di Bruno brothers let's take a look
so this is 18 a pound okay so so it's
basically half the price of the breber
roosta argental and sometimes I've seen
it on sale for much much less so keep an
eye on that uh maybe Trader Joe's even
has a telegio I'm not sure
not sure but I would definitely keep an
eye on it beautiful cheese not I mean
perfect you know perfect cheese I don't
know it's a very good cheese very very
good cheese
okay
um what cheese do I use for grilled
cheese you know I I don't know you know
this I'm not Jay Kenji Lopez alt
um but for me I try to do a mix of
cheeses what I'll often do for a grilled
cheese is I'll do
a mild or sharp cheddar but then I'll
mix it with something else if you want
kind of like a um
I don't know if you wanted to if you
want to with a little bit of a kick you
can do pepper jack and cheddar
um I like provolone it's a lot of people
aren't big on provolone they're like it
doesn't really taste like anything I
think provolone with sharp cheddar is a
is a pretty good idea
uh honestly any cheese you like you can
use it I mean I probably wouldn't use
like
you know like rockefort or something
like that in a in a grilled cheese I
don't know if it's the or you know I
don't know that I would do feta from a
consistency standpoint but all right
anyway let's move on I want to say
thanks to my brother hates parties man
as well as Enchanted leafy artist for
the twitch Prime subscriptions numbers
24 and 25. also a big thank you to
Jonathan grabiel who just signed up on
my website joinpakman.com that puts us
at 26. if we get just to 50 we've set an
intermediate goal we will look at the
Dave Rubin interview with Lauren bobert
it's crazy it's crazy and we're getting
there pretty quick I want to say thanks
to John Franco saracino for signing up
on my website with the coupon code
felony21 today's special code is sinks
and showers we're looking very strongly
at sinks and showers but you can really
use any coupon code that you want okay
all right other super chats
um for your information internet archive
bypasses article paywalls as long as the
article has been archived very good
Patrick says I live about 15 minutes
away from the Boise Mall given the
politics around here I'm confident
nothing will change that may be the case
David sir montamore by Sartori Cheese is
Sublime
let's take a look at that
montamore by Sartori
montemore cheddar
to reserve okay
is it cheddar that tastes like parmesan
or parmesan that tastes like cheddar oh
boy
third place in the 2016 American cheese
Society contest wow
all right I've not heard of that one but
I will keep an eye on it that is
interesting to me
that is very very interesting to me okay
what do you guys want to go to next do
you want to go with some people losing
their minds in public or do you want to
go to voicemails what do people want
next we'll do both
we'll do both for sure but what do
people want first
all right looks like people are more
into some of the clips I've got all
right let's go to some clips here
um okay
this California high school teacher says
he's willing to fight the vaccine
mandate even if it means losing his job
he only answers to God and his wife not
the government
sounds pretty edgy let's take a look
like this mandate for my family and my
community if it means I lose my money
because fighting it hurts your community
John I'll be able to sleep at night
knowing I stood up for freedom and I am
certain that history will say that I'm
on the right side of science as well no
that is almost certainly not the case
not the government
wow now I I want to mention as I've said
before there's a whole other Mo impetus
for among a lot of the people that are
promoting the chaos at the school boards
they want a private they don't want the
government involved in education they
don't want public schools and so even if
the individual people protesting aren't
even aware that this is something that's
going on
um there's a whole underbelly of right
Wingers who love this because it just
makes Public Schools seem very chaotic
it might get some parents to say oh my
God it's so Bonkers at school I'm
pulling my kid we'll go private I'll
home school or whatever which then
depending on how public schools are
funded in different districts weakens
the public school further so you have to
understand that that's a big motivating
factor for a lot of this okay here is
um
I don't know is this Matt schlapp I
don't actually know what the guy looks
like this might be Matt and mercy is
this Matt schlapp's daughter Mercy
because I know it's Matt and Mercedes
schlap is Mercy
is this the wife the daughter I have no
idea anyway check out this crowd how
they go completely nuts when Trump calls
into their event this is this is
a cult
an undeniable cult
sir
sir your wife is up in the air okay
well I just want to thank everybody
[Applause]
wow these are really special people huh
let's watch it once more
today who wants
Mr President sir how are you
well I just want to thank everybody
completely insane completely and totally
Off the Wall bonkers
uh all right so we got that
um this is really good this is a really
nicely edited video I I saw this earlier
I wanted to bring it to you fine folks
well that sounds fun I mean I don't know
who those people are but that sounds
great
[Music]
send in some money it sounds great have
a wonderful time we
we got a Max card
oh fantastic that sounds wonderful you
know you gotta have safety protocols in
place got to keep the community safe I
love it
what do you mean you don't agree with
this
of course you agree with this see right
here before you can even go to buy the
tickets you get the health check that's
required where it very clearly states
that you know you'll have a negative
Code test within 72 hours of the event
or you know show a vaccine card or you
know get a test there and then you
agreed to it you had to have otherwise
you couldn't even have bought the ticket
right here I agree dude right there you
push that and then you agreed so is it
that you don't remember or you don't
think that it applies to because
there it is yes this is America this is
a country where private companies can
require certain things of their patrons
and that Patron can either agree to
those guidelines or not participate or
patronize that business much like
wearing a shirt or shoes in order to go
to a restaurant you have to agree to
those things or you cannot come in
more or less all businesses do it
America so was it that you just thought
that it wouldn't apply to you because
sorry she scared me
she's a little Goblin yes this is
America where the rules apply to yes
even you
and what is it that
so many people often say people a lot
like you ah yes I remember if you don't
like it you can leave
[Laughter]
okay anyway so here this is just a wet
now there was oh there was another one
oh man there was another similar video
of someone who had
assume there's no way they would even be
there had they not agreed where they
were then kicked out for no vaccine but
I don't remember now let me see if I can
find it
kicked out vaccine let me see if I can
find it
um
a black family kicked out by a white man
in a restaurant for failing to show
proof of vaccine
what's that is that I mean is is the
race of the people relevant in this one
let's see
you're refusing service
are you refusing service
so you so you're going to enforce
segregation because we just told you
that we're religiously Exempted
I never told you any of that I would
never tell you that I would never tell
you that I would never say that
it's a little bit
um
you're sort of baiting when if you I
don't know anything about this but it's
like if you go in and accuse a place of
segregation and you're black and the
person telling you you got to be
vaccinated is white
um you're kind of baiting in a way right
I mean I don't know it's it's
[Music]
okay go and read it Go and read it Go
and read it and you tell me we're not
leaving also is he being are they being
segregated by religion by race or
vaccination status because he's claiming
a religious exemption
[Music]
yeah I mean like is the guy I'm saying
here it says a black family I don't I'm
not assessing the guy's race
everybody in here is okay with that
everybody's in here okay with with seven
seven segregation in society everybody's
okay with that oh we don't have a
vaccine cards so now the kids can't eat
we can't eat you guys are okay with that
this is the America you want a little
bit hyperbolic to say they can't eat I
mean if they're in the restaurant
presumably they have money for food you
don't need a vaccine card to go to the
grocery store
America you want to live in no [ __ ] you
you see you're not American that's why
you need to get the [ __ ] out of here if
you're not American all right get the
[ __ ] out of here the kids are learning a
very important lesson here I don't know
what it is but it's clear that there's
an important lesson being learned
[Applause]
this is America you need to wake up this
is the kind of country you want to live
in you want to live I like this guy is
this guy surreptitiously filming like
he's kind of acting like he's not but he
seems to very clearly be filming type of
country
everybody's okay with this
[Applause]
no that's that's not the point that's
not the point that's not the point
[Music]
I told you I told you that we're
religiously exempt if you read
stick on your thing from the city it
says you cannot discriminate okay read
the poster it says it on there
all right I'm guessing they didn't come
to any kind of agreement uh let me see
if I can find the video I was actually
looking for
uh wasn't these people being kicked out
for no vaccine
no
man I wish I remembered exactly what it
was
this is the same one we just saw
man kicked out of mass vaccination
Center for asking about ingredients
okay
senior kicked out of a McDonald's after
not being able to provide proof of
vaccination geez
all right yeah I I think unless I
remember more about the specifics I'm
not going to be able to find it like
this
okay all right well listen if I come
across it if I find it I will uh I will
let everybody know about it thanks to
ones comp and major Blazer as well as
Outlaw Cecil Owen Rock and C missile for
re-upping twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 32
also a huge thank you to Rosemary
snedden who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code felony21 Rafael
Suarez who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code sinks and showers
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers and DJ Douglas who signed up on
the website with the coupon code better
21. that puts us at 35. we haven't we're
very close at 50. we are doing the Dave
Rubin Lauren bobert clips and they're
wild it's it's really something else let
me get to a few super chats then I'm
going to do some voicemails and then
we'll we'll see where we are
um David Texas passed a new redistricted
map and it's crazily gerrymandered yeah
we talked about it
David I was in Montreal two weeks ago
and proof of vaccine was omnipresent no
loud pushback anywhere it was so
refreshing yeah some of my family was
recently in Montreal they said it was uh
it was pretty pretty solid okay we're
standing by for a press conference on
the shooting in uh in Boise Okay so
we've got that coming up
what Justice will there be for the
Traders unfortunately I'm worried I'm
worried there will be none I assume
you're referring to the now
increasingly specific uh uh allegations
that the January 6 protest organizers
um coordinated with members of Congress
and even White House staff I worry there
will be no consequences that's my
concern
David do restaurants not have the right
to refuse service yeah they do
they do they don't have the right to
refuse service on the basis of race or
religion though so when the guy says I'm
religiously exempt from the vaccine
the idea is if you kick them out you're
now refusing service on the basis of
religion which would be against the law
which would be against the law so that's
why they're they the guy seems to know
that
and he's deliberately
muddying the waters I guess is uh the
way I would say it
um okay let's do a few voicemails let's
do a few voicemails
after we until as we await the um start
of this press conference of course uh oh
hold on here oh wait new caller
I'm gonna play this one
it's it goes the full three minutes and
it seems a little rambly but let's try
it
hey David uh just wanted to ask you a
quick question like I definitely hear
um you know you play voicemails with
people who support what you do as well
as someone against
uh some of the things that you're saying
like the anti-vaxxers and things of that
nature so I was just curious to know if
you actually
other than playing what they say or what
voicemails they leave
for you and then you know play it on
your show show do you actually reach
back out to those people and respond to
them to see if there is any way that you
can possibly no I'm not then if the
question is do I call the people who
leave me voicemails off air the answer
is no
I'm not doing that okay
um Whitney has something to say
um first didn't
understand nice
um and uh
um
he was like talking about the
coronavirus
um about how like the vaccine sometimes
like he was hearing rumors
about it
um
um what is it called like a sterilizing
men all right uh thank you Whitney let's
move on hi David this is a response to
your video on Steve Bannon I definitely
think they are trying to ramp up another
attack
um not only is it their best interest to
uh well
um to ramp up for another attack for for
Steven to get more clicks
I think by attacking again you basically
protect the people who attacked before
because you swamped the justice system
basically
all right Whitney's back
so I studied um anatomy and art school
and um one of the things that like I
look at sometimes are like cultural
differences between people and like the
shapes of their heads and faces and
stuff like that okay dabbling in a
little phrenology very good
David what's going on man it's Zach
again from Tennessee
um second time caller now no big deal
um anyways I'm watching your video on
Michael and Dell again and his [ __ ]
that he likes to talk about but anyways
my question is biometric voting yes I
mean it seems to be it seems I don't
know both parties should be screaming
for it from heaven
it would I mean if they really want the
country to beat that
what advantage is
not going to biometric voting
okay
uh uh yeah
so I wanted to respond to like the
Afghanistan Wars if you're looking for
your old videos and I thought that they
were like selling heroin to people
hello
I just don't
know what to say
all right very good
now this is like she's widely available
I have no obligation to wear a mask
anywhere
period
that's where the real world works
because that's another one of Shadows
okay thank you
so I was wondering what your opinion of
like um celebrities
like in regards to
um like the
um
the social aspect or like um like I
don't want to see culture because I
don't really find it like cultural
um but like I okay it would be great if
we could hear this press conference I
can't see off screen that I've been
talking to about this spice so we're
going to turn to Emmy Award when he
talks about Tavern Hall why are why
aren't we able to hear that I'm trying
to hear that uh anybody know where that
because we're trying to hear the oh hold
on here we go here we go here we go
accident
we are working together the families of
any one two
[Music]
people were killed in this event
we're still working with
both the hospitals as well as our
investigators to notify family we would
ask that the community at large keep
their families in of the deceased in
their thoughts and that they also people
have died of any of the immediately
affected in the community
yeah
at a very high level Overview at around
150 this afternoon officers responded to
reports of shots being fired at the
Boise Mall
with reports that at least one person
was shot and down wow
shortly after responding on scene
officers encountered an individual
matching assessments description
and there was a change of gunfire that
ensued shortly thereafter
resulting in the officer's injury as
well as a suspect being taken into
custody
at this time the majority of the mall
has been cleared we are still actively
clearing them all
to both look for any additional concerns
and any additional victims but at this
time we believe that there was only a
single shooter involved and that there
is no ongoing threat or danger of the
committee at large from this incident
again this is an ongoing investigation
as well as attachable incident we really
cannot at this time speak to any
motivation behind it or anything else
that may impact the investigation it
would be entirely too premature to make
any of those assumptions I recognize
that the community is going to have many
questions as well as concern the Boise
Police Department will work to make sure
that we get that information out to the
community as quickly as possible in
conjunction with both our investigators
and our prosecutors
because this involves an officer
involved shooting the critical incident
task force for Aid accounting has been
activated they will be leading the
investigation into the officer-involved
shooting portion of this the other
events that occurred inside and outside
the mall will be conducted as an
investigation by the Boise Police
Department again we will share further
information as soon as we can but our
thoughts and prayers go out to the
family of those affected as well as the
concern for the community
without I'd like to turn the microphone
over to our mayor or McLean
all right so it appears someone was
killed he said deceased
I first want to speak to the families of
those who were hurt today
never should one have to or does one
expect when they're saying goodbye to
their loved one who's headed to work
who's headed out to shop
and that they'll get a call like they
did today
countless people found themselves in
such a situation they never would have
nor should have expected
I want to thank
the shopkeepers the people in this in
the mall that reacted so quickly to take
care of folks that were there you showed
in a tough and chaotic moment how much
you care and what you're willing to do
to support and care for our strength for
strangers
I also want to thank the Boise Police
Department and First Responders
we came quickly
you showed compassion
to so many people that were scared at a
really tough moment and you did
everything you could to keep people safe
and on that I want to reiterate what the
chief has said people still in the mall
are safe
people in Boise are safe your safety is
our priority
as we think about
those that were hurt today my heart goes
out to
those who sheltered in place
those who saw this crime
those who weren't sure if they'd see a
loved one again or who knew that they
had someone they cared about in the mall
I am deeply deeply sorry for the pain
and Trauma that you've experienced no
one should have to experience that pain
and Trauma and particularly those whose
family members are lost today I am so
sorry
I'm gonna ask Boise
and ask all of the media to please
respect the families the privacy of our
of the families who were impacted today
to acknowledge the trauma that they are
experiencing and will experience to
direct all questions through the police
department and to know that we will
share as much as we can when we can as
soon as we can because this
investigation is ongoing
and finally I'm just going to ask once
more that we respect the privacy of
these residents our neighbors our
friends and neighbors who were hurt
today and that we think about all that
we can do to lift them up in the coming
hours days and weeks to show that this
community cares about them that we will
respect their privacy they will do
everything we can to keep everyone safe
thank you very much
[Applause]
police officer injured and two dead
correct
at this time the total number injured in
it and that we know at this time is six
that would include an injured officer as
well as two individuals who were killed
oh I mean I make a distinction between
these someone who's died
you have basically two deceased and four
others injured including an officer okay
as well as additional people that we are
processing to make sure they're suspect
in custody
the suspect is in custody
can you tell us how I'm not answering
any questions at this time because of
the investigation
again because of the ongoing nature of
the investigation we're not Fielding
questions thank you very much
all right so what was initially reported
as a mass shooting in which six people
were injured including an officer it's
actually two people were killed and then
an additional four were injured
including an officer so that's the
latest we have right now
and uh it happened uh again right I mean
another shooting another shooting and
many people's reaction is there's just
no way to prevent this
people from the only country where this
regularly happens say there's there's
just no way you just can't
you can't prevent it there's no way to
prevent it which just doesn't really
Square for me
doesn't really make sense
um a few other super chats coming in
David what religion makes a person
exempt from vaccination I'm not actually
aware of any I think what it is when
people say they have a religious
exemption exemption is like their
specific wacky Pastor is like don't get
it
but I'm not sure that I know of any
um
of any religion that just flat out says
do not get vaccinated if other people do
then let me uh let me let me know
maybe Jehovah's Witnesses yeah maybe
Jehovah's Witnesses
but I'm not even sure I'm not even sure
I think in fact actually no hold on a
second hold on a second
I think I got an email from a Jehovah's
Witness not long ago
um
who might have said they do get
vaccinated
okay I'm not finding it I'm not finding
it that even there I want to be careful
because that may not even be true Ethan
asks whether I'm going to take calls
well that's up to you Ethan here's what
we have if we get to 50 today in members
and twitch we'll we'll look at the Dave
Rubin Lauren bobert Clips if we get to
100 we'll open phone lines we're
actually getting very close Kino Hermes
has just resubscribed on Twitch that's
putting us at number 36. we then have to
add to that
Ross McNamee who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code sinks and
showers we're looking very strongly at
sinks and showers Richard fakowski just
signed up on my website
and Sarah Torres also signed up on my
website that puts us at 39 so we're only
11 away from doing the the Dave Rubin
Lauren bobert clips
and all re everything counts re-subs on
Twitch
um the font Peg just signed up via
twitch and then Jay tanned away gifted
five so that already gets us to 45.
H hate to lose it gave out another five
so that puts us we're at 50. we're at
50. all right okay good so we did that
let me start getting the um
let me start getting the Lauren bobert
Clips together because we did it okay we
did it folks here's the first one this
this is just vile vile stuff and what's
interesting about this interview is
remember Dave Rubin was supposedly like
the last real liberal he's a thinker
he's a cultural critic he's an analyst
um but now Dave Rubin voted Trump and is
nodding along to what Lauren bobert says
one of the most radical members of
Congress complete lunatic right winger
so let's go to clip number one of four
I just pulled my kids out of public
school because they brought back Mass
mandates and whoa they're not letting up
on it and I said okay well we're doing
something else because I'm not
subjecting my children to this again and
uh and so we're pulling them out and
doing something on our own but are you
homeschooling now it'll be a hybrid
version
are you are you homeschooling now
um as if it would be perfectly logical
to put to put your kids in homeschooling
because they need masks which is shown
to reduce transmission it's crazy
you're homeschooling now right all right
clip number two here we go keep us so
divided and so separate and previous uh
members of Congress who have been there
previously they'll tell you it's never
been this way
um there was always communication
between Republicans and Democrats and
now it is so divided and that's by
Design she wants to keep us separate she
wants the house Chambers empty you're
talking about you're talking about dance
Nancy Pelosi yes right oh yeah yeah yeah
his contributions like actively are just
making it clear that he's fully off the
deep end and and she truly believes this
is Pelosi's house do you guys think
Lauren bobert is Whitney the regular
caller is that possible
now I'm actually thinking it's possible
all right so that's clip number two she
says Nancy Pelosi wants the house empty
why would she want the house empty not
clear but Dave rubin's like you're
talking about Nancy right Nancy Pelosi
oh yeah
clip number three
hold on a sec
Pelosi has called me the Enemy Within
um we have metal detectors outside of
the house Chambers because of me and uh
or so so it seems well that's really
funny wow you are such a danger and you
refuse to just follow rules to the point
where they maybe have been forced to put
metal detectors at the door what a thing
to be proud of I made it so that they
needed to escalate security
at my place of work when your place of
work puts in place security measures to
protect other co-workers from you it's
not exactly something to be proud of
okay and then now clip number four and
this is just this one's wild I objected
to the Electoral College results because
the Constitution was violated and that's
our biggest threat right now is the
complete disregard of the Constitution
now
a real question to ask here would be
Lauren now I know this is a crazy
question to come up with this is you'd
have to really be thinking you know
Lauren um
in what ways was the Constitution
violated
that's the full question that's it
that's the full question and then
you see what happens
um
oh there's there's more let me see if I
can find more of it um
Dave Rubin bobert let's see if I can
find other clips
oh full interview oh let's check this
out actually
it's to state government for help I've
I've stood in line for government cheese
I've stood in line for bread and I knew
at 11 years old that that was not
America's best that there was more for
us we didn't live that way in Florida I
we didn't have to pay with Monopoly
money for groceries in the grocery store
and that's what we were doing in
Colorado
my stepdad he ended up getting work in
Aspen when I was about 12 and we moved
to the Western Slope of Colorado and
that really was the best thing that
could have ever happened to us we moved
into a community that wasn't just
telling us where to get yeah I don't
know why it starts like this with no
introduction oh I guess then they go to
an introduction a handout but they were
offering a hand up
all right I'm Dave Rubin and we are live
in studio today with the congresswoman
from Colorado's Third District Lauren
bobert welcome to the Reuben report
thanks so much for having me on Dave
this is fantastic to actually be in
person with someone talking face to face
imagine that face to face we've got what
about four feet between us are we in any
sort of legal trouble could this get you
kicked out I mean
listen even bringing guns doesn't seem
to even participating in the planning of
the January 6 Riot doesn't seem to get
you kicked out according to political
science we are in deep trouble right now
what about regular science I know
political yeah we're in a lot of trouble
I think I think we're okay with regular
science all right we got you all the way
out to Crazy California and you're here
for a couple days how do you feel in
California you come from the I would say
relatively free state of Colorado or the
once really free state hanging on Free
State yes we are hanging on I do believe
that there are more conservatives in
Colorado than the average person person
would would know we are slowly turning
into California and really it's been
quicker than any of us would have liked
to have seen but we have a governor from
California who wants to mimic everything
that's that's happened here uh there's
been it's biomimicry documentaries that
have gone out the Rocky Mountain Heist
there's a book uh the Colorado blueprint
and uh you know they they were kind of
sounding the alarms of what was
happening and that Colorado was really a
petri dish for all of these liberal
policies that Democrats want to
take Nationwide and if they can do it in
Colorado they can do it anywhere
successfully and so that's what we're
seeing and we didn't have any voices in
Colorado so I'm really happy
um to be that loud voice in Colorado
right now to let everyone know what's
happening to us there yeah and I've done
a couple events in Colorado over the
last couple years although unfortunately
none in the lab I'm feeling yeah second
hand I saw that
um secondhand embarrassment
I'm feeling embarrassed for both of
these people a year and a half but when
I was on tour with Jordan Peterson I
went and a few other things I noticed
when I talked to a lot of people was
Dave Dave could you uh make sure all the
California people stopped coming here
yeah are you still hearing a lot about
that yes we still have Californians
coming and these political refugees are
bringing their bad policies with them
and so I mean that's really devastating
to our communities because we like our
rural way of life do you guys hear that
it sounded like like some something just
happened in the background there we
don't want that uh those that urban life
because I have I have dogs I have goats
now but Clyde does have to leave
so sweet
oh
you love me we could be in trouble here
well we have the outtake for the show
Craig you gotta go now hi guys we have a
treat or uh
what a relatable moment guys that brings
me a lot of joy I love I love animals
yes I have four boys so I love animals
okay wild yeah so people are constantly
opening the door and breaking into your
interviews sorry you were saying
uh I I don't know where we were
um but with uh with everything that's
that's where were we we were talking
about The Californians coming is Reuben
out of focus slightly I'm actually
unclear he seems slightly out of focus
to me it's weird and they're bringing
their bad policies with them and so we
there really is an urban and rural
divide and uh we want to keep rural
Colorado rule but unfortunately in these
high Mountain Ski Resort towns that I
represent a lot of Californians can
afford to move there and they're
bringing the same policies that they're
fleeing from so listen all the money
these Californians are bringing when
they go to Aspen we've really got to
stop it right away so I asked this to
every conservative or republican uh
official that I talk to like when the
people
do you think they have no idea that they
voted for those policies that they're
now fleeing and realize that maybe they
should think about things a little bit
aren't they going for vacation what does
he made lit fleeing differently now no I
it I mean because their actions would
prove that they think they can flee from
their problems and unfortunately there
is a lower class
of people who cannot afford to flee
those bad policies that they have voted
in and implemented and so they something
about how she says lower class sounds
pejorative to leave pack up and and go
to somewhere with lower taxes and better
opportunities and still have a beautiful
scenic view but there is another class
that's left behind that cannot afford to
make that same move congresswoman you've
now been directly tied to the
Insurrection do you think you will ever
actually face consequences for your
complete abortive attack on the uh
pillars of democracy of this country and
they are the ones who are stuck and well
Dave that's really funny you ask that
you know when in Colorado people from
California show up it's really not good
and uh in that terrible economy and a
horrible state where they are left now
to depend on the government to help uh
it's funny how this entire California
attack it's like California has one of
the most dynamic economies in the world
if California were a country it would be
growing as quickly as some developing
countries that are experiencing rapid
growth and it's a state that's been
around for a long time I don't know what
what year California became a state in
do they have a homelessness problem yes
they do
um but uh
we have a country that how many
Industries are overwhelmingly based in
California I mean it's it's a CR this
entire attack California thing is crazy
in their situations or or
um even in these failing economies where
taxes are just too high to afford the
homes that they want to live in um so I
mean it's really impacts them more than
anything uh and then they come to these
other states and and bring those same
policies so I wouldn't think that they
knew uh what impact they are having on
these communities yeah the idea that
they're leaving the people who can't
afford to move is sort of interesting
too you know I realized this morning
when I was thinking about how I wanted
to do this interview that you know it
was a really bad idea but unfortunately
it was too late and I'm a right winger
now so I said let her come in but send
the dog in to make it all funny you take
sort of the new crop of Congress people
and you think about mostly the Democrats
is it possible that that's a green
screen it almost looks like
something is weird about this shot does
anybody agree with me that there's
something's weird about this it almost
looks like a green screen and Reuben is
lit completely differently
like
do these Shadows even make sense I don't
even know Something's Strange here I
don't know nothing wrong with using a
green screen I use one when I travel
just everything about this is strange
outside we all know everything about AOC
no I guess that's real right is it
there's no that it's a real
I don't know I don't know what to make
of it see we know everything about ilhan
Omar probably too much more than we want
to know we know everything about Ayanna
Presley and the rest of the crew but we
don't actually know that much from a
national perspective about you and it's
like it seems like people should be
talking about you just as much uh but
that's not really how the media operates
because you're a scary conservative no
it's because she's an idiot and she
doesn't know anything let's skip ahead
and just see a little of some something
else we're not going to do all of this
obviously looking up to that
um
certainly I don't think that this is a
president that obtained 81 million votes
you know I think he would have a little
bit of confidence in his in his base to
at least answer questions
um if this was such a popular president
but I mean that that's neither neither
here nor there but I
actually if she doesn't think Biden
really got the votes he reportedly got
it is a big deal that's a big deal
that's crazy I objected to the Electoral
College results because the Constitution
was violated and that's our biggest
threat right now is the complete
disregard of the Constitution of the
United States you know you could go and
try to find votes in Arizona votes in
Georgia whatever hundreds of thousands
of votes ballots were mailed out right
in our faces against state constitutions
and the Federal Constitution
um meaning because we change procedures
because of covid basically right exactly
that's not unconstitutional because the
state Reuben likes it but it's that's
not unconstitutional legislature has the
right to change election laws and in Six
States in particular it was not the
state legislatures that did that
um no no legislator uh passed a law like
that we had Rogue judges attorneys
generals
um secretaries of states and unelected
bureaucrats changing election laws and
so I mean that that's the big
that's what everyone's missing right
Dave come on there that is why me and
146 other Republicans objected that's
why I
and other Republicans objected please
Lauren
in January and and then this has just
been spun out of control and we gotta
find ten thousand ballots so we gotta
find 20 000 ballots no hundreds of
thousands were mailed out illegally
right in front of your faces
it was against the Constitutions what
percentage of your constituents do you
think Care Fall for this [ __ ] about this
because I can tell you after this
California recall that obviously didn't
go the way that I wanted to but uh yeah
okay for and after almost everybody that
I spoke to and I campaigned with Larry
Elder almost everyone that I spoke to
you might literally be everyone I spoke
to during the campaign said Dave do you
trust what's going to happen with the
results right that one was fake too guys
that was a fraudulent election too
they're already that's their way of
saying I don't trust what's going to
happen with the results so now we've got
like this this almost parasite in the
system now of belief right or lack of
yes and that is very concerning because
it's funny
they act like the fact that the right
doesn't trust elections is evidence that
the elections can't be trusted when in
reality the fact that the right doesn't
trust elections is a reaction to the
story that Donald Trump told where he
said 2016 couldn't be trusted even
though he won electorally and in advance
he said you weren't going to be able to
trust 2020 and it became a meme
the fact that they've fallen for you
can't trust the results they're saying
clearly you can't trust them because we
don't it's like no that's that's
specious reasoning Dave because it I
would say high 90s uh High 90 percent uh
of the folks that follow me and are
voting don't have trust in our election
um anyway I think that's enough but when
when the average kind of like uh trumpy
you know whatever watches this who do
you think they see as more of the
Thinker Dave Rubin or Lauren bober when
they watch an interview like this what
do people think
like who do they see as the intellectual
heavyweight here
Reuben's dog yeah that's actually that's
probably not that's probably true
that's not that's not that's not wrong
throw him the hell out of here
um
the camera Tech who came in yeah okay
all right uh very very good very good
okay I'm falling behind on a variety of
thank yous let me make let me get caught
up here thank you to the following
people let's see how close we get to a
hundred Texas bear claw Toca tacos Chef
Melville Bethany folks r Tyler e
and Matthew Romans have all re-upped or
created new twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 56 and over on the website
uh nothing happening over on the website
okay if we get to a hundred and we let
me see hold on we're at 56 out of 100.
what percent is that that's
five
[Music]
we're 56 of the way to where we need to
be and the coupon code sinks and showers
saves you 69 percent we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers Obama
[Music]
uh that is the best all right
um let's see if we can quickly talk to
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benell II I'm
gonna check in with him
via Discord and see if he wants to catch
up real quick
let's see
hey are you streaming
long time want to connect and catch up
let's see if Stephen
is streaming
he's playing league right now oh okay so
we may not be able to do it then
that's too bad I mean I don't even know
what that means but
hmm
yeah I don't know my audience goes back
and forth between liking and not liking
Steven so I I honestly I have no idea
thanks to Elias His Highness for
grabbing a twitch Prime subscription
your number 57 today which is a
tremendous number I think a couple
people may be about to grab website
memberships in which case I will
absolutely thank them oh hold on
Destiny's here hold on hold on let's see
if we can get on with Steven
Hey Stephen
how you doing how are you
doing great What's um I heard that you
were moving you were moving out of
California is that true
um yeah I think I'm going to Florida
okay when what's the reason for that
um I've got other friends in Florida
cheaper cost of living like why not oh
okay are you going to the one place in
Florida that makes sense or elsewhere
it's the one place afford to make since
Miami or well yeah okay yeah that's what
I'm going that's very good okay uh nice
and are you are you thinking of bringing
back like a like doing a streamer house
there or something [ __ ] no okay I ever
want to live with degenerate [ __ ]
streamers I might partner up with you on
that I would do a streamer house with
you and if it was on uh Miami Beach
maybe yeah
okay well well I'm moving to Miami Beach
so we'll see okay oh all right well
we'll be in touch how can I okay are you
saying how soon you're leaving
um probably within a month oh wow a lot
of people to live in the house though
you know I don't want to have like the I
don't want to have the gusano to normal
population be too high you know sorry
sorry that was the goose the gusana what
Tom Rumble the the gusano to normal
person popular too high so we'll have to
find a bunch of other safe people to
move in you know oh I see okay yeah yeah
um have you weighed in on uh on Hassan's
computer
um I I mean it's just a meme computer
there's not much to say right yeah I
don't even know what's interesting about
it is it just that it's it's uh it's
just a memetic computer that's it
basically yeah yeah okay what are you
using these days anyway you're a PC guy
right yeah yeah
cool
um I I feel like I'm just completely out
you were you in Europe for a while
yeah I was in Europe for like a month
and a half um Netherlands and then
Sweden
um and then now I'm in uh America and
then I went to Omaha Nebraska for a
couple days went to New York now I'm
back in California yeah that's nice yeah
I'm gonna be out in California soon it's
gonna be it's gonna be quite a scene but
I think you I think you'll be gone
unfortunately like living there or just
no no visiting visiting okay gotcha were
you headed I'm gonna be all over I'm
going to be in San Diego I'm going to be
in LA
so you're not gonna be all over you're
gonna be in Southern California yeah
exactly all over in that small two-hour
driving radius okay gotcha all over that
particular area
okay yep and um yeah I mean maybe me you
and Hassan could go out to dinner again
if you're still there
yeah I don't think that's gonna happen I
don't know if his uh Security will let
me into his neighborhood but
okay yeah well we could we could
certainly talk about that
um what are you what what's been up with
like what are you streaming mostly these
days
you know I'm just I want to just get
into video games full-time because all
the political discourse online and even
in the real world is like just absolute
[ __ ] cancer so it's just like
watching it all unfold is just so
disgusting so yeah
are you is are you genuinely thinking of
doing that
um I don't know talking about politics
online is really sad and pathetic like
most of the commentators are like brain
dead like knuckle dragging [ __ ] to
watch like anybody all of the
conversations are just so horrible
there's so much I think they're worse
than they were five years ago
um and then just like watching the
cycles of like stuff becoming popular
and not popular and just where we are
like with all the discourses just so
disgusting I just like I don't know what
do you think is like the worst trendy
thing in political talk right now
the worst trendy thing it's definitely
like the like [ __ ] the rich for
everything it's just so cancerous it
doesn't get us anywhere it doesn't move
us in a better Direction on tax policy
it doesn't get us in a better place
socially it doesn't move any of the
conversations long in a productive way
um it's all just like a bunch of like
middle class white Suburban kids that
live in gated communities virtually
signaling to other white Suburban kids
living in gated communities on Twitter
about how like hard it is being poor in
the U.S and how evil billionaires are
even though their mom and dads are
probably like top one percent earners
like on their own like it's just it's so
annoying and stupid what is a gated
community anyway
okay like you live in a place where in
order to drive in you've got to like
there's a guy at the gate that lets
people in like you have to either talk
to a dude or you get rung in or you have
to like dial a code or whatever right
okay so you're literally saying you're
not you're not using it as a euphemism
even just for like rich neighborhoods
you're saying specifically
actual gated communities yes like the
only black people these people have ever
seen their lives are like on the wire or
something yes like those types
oh man that seems like maybe a bit of a
straw man in terms of the actual
problems with the discourse though it
seems like a bit absolutely not a bit of
an identity attack studies right now
preposterous the identities on Twitter
are so overwhelmingly white college
educated and middle class yeah like you
see this pop up like over and over and
over again and you had a huge problem
during the discourse in the last
presidential election cycle
um with the Democrats just missing their
marks because one they treat every brown
person in the US like the same person
which is [ __ ] stupid right so you've
got these dumb white kids talking about
how awesome socialism is to people that
fled like Venezuela which doesn't look
good and then you've got people
pretending that like oh yeah uh black
people in Hispanic people hate cops too
right running around like the acap [ __ ]
which also didn't play well so like the
online discourse isn't managed to I
thought that I thought that there was
like a huge difference between like
online discourse versus real life
discourse and there is but the problem
is that all the real life [ __ ] is
starting to move online
um so it's managed to like toxify like
the real life political conversations
because those people are all becoming
more online as well yeah I think I
actually one where I agree with you on
this is like there's this entire
movement now I even bookmarked a couple
of these articles to be able to refer to
them to uh refer to them like for
example
um hold on let me see if I find them
here uh
I'm not actually finding an example but
basically stuff about like
here's 10 techniques for your morning
routine to prevent burnout and it's like
you know the people who really need that
aren't able to have a 10-step morning
routine because they're busy like
working two jobs or whatever the case
may be it it's it I think it's a sort of
similar Dynamic to what you're you're
kind of getting at
um yeah maybe it depends yeah I find
that like a lot of um usually when
people talk about like poor struggles in
the United States it's pretty
overwhelmingly obvious that they don't
know what they're talking about so like
for instance and I'm going to trigger
the [ __ ] out of a lot of like fake white
kids in your chat I'm sorry to do this
but like anytime people talk like oh
yeah like being homeless or um being
poor in America is so hard like going to
bed like starving every night like poor
people poor working people in America
aren't starving to death okay this
doesn't happen you have no idea like
what the poor experience is like you're
just you watch like a movie about like
[ __ ] Uganda and you're assuming that
like poor people in the United States
like it's just it's a total disconnect
from the lived experiences or why being
poor sucks or like why these issues are
issues or you know what it's like living
in these circumstances but they want to
like speak for all of these poor and
oppressed people anyways because they
have nothing else going on in their life
but wait a second you don't deny that
there is food insecurity in the United
States you're just saying there's not
it's not abject poverty in the same way
do you know what food insecurity means
nobody actually knows what this term
means you can go and look at I think
it's the USDA that defines it food
insecurity can mean as much as like um
um [ __ ] I have to go back and look at it
but when people hear food insecurity
they assume that food insecurity means
that you're not eating that's not true
food insecurity might just mean that
you're not getting like a well-balanced
mix of vitamins and minerals like your
micronutrients aren't like in check
that's what food insecurity come in and
you can go the definition is probably
you're looking on the UC website I'm
looking at it whoa whoa whoa whoa hold
on I'm looking at it right now it says
it says it's a lack of consistent access
to enough food for an active healthy
lifestyle so it seems to just be talking
about calories it doesn't seem to be
absolutely not I've been my life on it
we can well I mean we have it up on the
screen but I mean
no I mean like if you can literally if
you work in any poor place you'll know
this if you look at any homeless people
you know this like homeless people in
America and poor working people in
America aren't all like skinny and
starving no that's true that's true
that's true yeah
no no no that's not true that's not true
absolutely true if you've all homeless
people are fat that's crazy what are you
talking about but a lot or a lot of
Working Poor are are fat as [ __ ] right
well that's a different issue sure I'm
just saying that like the idea that poor
people in the United States are all
starving is not that's not a good
characterization of what it means to be
poor right as soon as I see somebody say
that I already know that they have no
idea what they're not being mean I'm
sorry this is like there's a bunch of
like disconnected topics here
um it's just there's a lot of
experiences in the United States that
aren't captured accurately like being
poor sucks for a wide variety of reasons
it's not because you're actually
starving to death okay it's not because
you're like I don't have enough calories
to eat and now my stomach is bloated
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like the kids
that lived in [ __ ] Auschwitz or
whatever no that's true I think that
there's basically like three or four
different things that you're and
everything single one of these could be
a conversation which we're not going to
do now like the Working Poor the Working
Poor being overweight relays relates to
the subsidies of foods that are cheap on
a per calorie basis and people who have
limited funds going well if I can buy a
hundred calories of vegetables or 500 of
crackers for the same two bucks I'm
gonna get the cheaper calories right so
I mean these are all different if
they're all real issues and they're
different for sure and they tie together
if you're from an upper class family or
middle class family you're much more
likely to have better education when it
comes to like healthy eating and like
taking the time to learn how to cook and
prepare meals and having the time to
cook and prepare meals because if you're
working a full-time job or two jobs or
whatever you don't always have time to
like you know do that are you off
sucrose
I don't know what the [ __ ] that means
right no that's the trendy thing are you
do you do like green drinks and stuff
I don't know what I don't know what any
of that means that's good you're
actually you're you're answering these
questions correctly in a lot of ways
um okay wow but so then we I guess where
we were was so from a from the
standpoint of profitability would just
be going full-time games make sense from
your business standpoint
um I don't care I mean I've already made
way too much money anyway so I can live
off less if I need to oh you make too
much are you donating big time
you're not okay
interesting I was trying to save enough
money so that if I get banned from
everything I'll like have enough to live
for the rest of my life do you think you
could be obligations yeah in terms of
like what I want to have saved then I'd
probably start doing more like
charitable stuff but do you feel as
though you're at risk of a full
cancellation
yeah of course I get like banned from
all sorts of random [ __ ] all the time
for like random [ __ ] reasons so
uh man I I just think or any of the
people in your chat if anybody ever
wants to chat with me on any of these
issues I'll be glad to like put them
through the [ __ ] ringer okay because
like everything I've said is 100 sure
this far if you disagree with anything
feel free to hop on afterwards another
thing that's irritating too is that like
all these socialist Lefty [ __ ] have
gotten like all these conservatives
banned from every platform too but then
all of the lefties are too scared to
talk because they won't step outside
their giant [ __ ] like Circle Jerks
because they know that they're like
ill-informed on literally every topic
that they make YouTube videos about so
not only can I like not talk to
conservatives anymore because they're
all banned from everything all of the
[ __ ] socialists like won't talk to
anybody either because they don't want
everyone to be challenged so it's like
it's the ultimate in like boring like
combinations of conditions online okay
wait but so I'm now I'm curious who's an
example of a of a socialist who got
someone banned but won't talk to others
oh my god
um like
um in terms of so like
vosh
um the Surfs
um who did vosh get banned like who did
well not not like these particular
people didn't get banned but like their
communities were like championed to get
people like banned from platforms and
stuff so I don't know vosh personally
has got anybody banned but like their
communities will run around and like
Mass report like any conservative or any
perceived conservative on the Internet
or whatever okay vasha's Community who
did they get banned
um I don't know like every time they
like run into like certain people you
have to go on the subreddit and find
like the threads of like report this
person
um for this [ __ ] or whatever
but have they successfully gotten anyone
banned have they successfully gone
Washington's Community are the one that
Amplified my writtenhouse tweet and got
me departed on Twitch but I mean like
there are other people too that these
guys like post about like pretty
relentlessly
um but you'd have to go on you'd have to
like look at the subreddit and [ __ ] well
I'm not the one who brought it up
sure I I don't keep track of every
I I I'm not ready to have like a
conversation like who have they
specifically attacked um but you can go
and like look through like subreddits
and watch it happen yeah now vosh does
vosh does do some engagement I feel like
with people on the right like he was
interviewed there's this guy who
he's sort of like another one of these
like he's the real liberal Tim pool I
don't know if you're familiar with him
and vosh engaged with him that's notable
I guess
yeah if they feel like they'll do well
they'll do it but if it's somebody
that's going to be challenging usually
they'll avoid it because they'll call it
irresponsible platforming or whatever if
you were me would you do an in-person
debate with Charlie Kirk
yeah of course you should why not he's
an incredibly popular figure online
right mm-hmm
yeah I'm I'm uh there's there have been
some initial
inquiries that have taken place so I'm
starting to ask around you would do it
you think it would be good for me to do
it
yeah of course any popular conservative
figure you should okay okay
um you doing okay because you seem on
edge today
uh well you caught me in the middle of
the league game so I'm already I'm
already off to a bad start yeah is
league triggering for you it's one of
the worst things that ever happened to
all of [ __ ] mankind almost as bad as
the online white socialist crowd not
quite as bad though but well it's up
there well what are you having for
breakfast these days
um on a gym day I'm usually eating
um
some kind of like oats and then um
days it'll just be a protein shake how
do you prepare the oats
oh I usually just pour it in a bowl uh
pour some milk sometimes microwave it
you wouldn't do them with you wouldn't
do oats with water right like that
should not even be legal I don't even
know I would just eat them raw before
doing something so disgusting yeah yeah
yeah
uh okay wow that's that's good
um all right any any questions for me
how have you been doing how's life you
know I've just been doing doing the
thing I was uh I was in Spain actually
uh a little bit ago
and almost got stuck there because of
some false positive covet tests
um
what else yeah I don't know not much to
tell we're just you know we're ramping
up for 2022 basically we got election
next week and just yeah you know just
kicking around
gotcha sounds like fun are you is there
a gun firing in the background
I live in L.A so there's always just
like a bunch of random stupid [ __ ] going
on outside oh okay seven thousand
decibels I don't know oh oh I know what
I wanted to ask you about I've been
seeing this new setup where you it's
basically you in a room with a blurry
background and a light that changes
color is this like your permanent
streaming setup now
um
a light and a background changing color
like where I'm at right now exactly yeah
yeah this is my apartment where I've
lived for over a year yeah but you're
you're the visual has changed over the
last maybe six months or something
um my visuals have changed
um no I mean in Europe it was different
oh okay okay David your chat triggers
the ever living [ __ ] out of me oh my God
why what's my what's my chat doing just
people saying the dumbest things when a
person uses the f word incessantly it's
a good indication of their inability to
communicate effectively I like when
people like try to break out thesauruses
to sound smart that's a vashware right
there I've ever saw on but um anyway
sorry Steven here's the last thing I
wanted to touch on if we were touching
David if we were to compile a list of
prominent Latino American streamers you
and I obviously would be on the list but
who else would be honest who else would
be on the list I don't know find
somebody that talks about killing
wealthy people and it spams acap on
their Twitter all day and then maybe
they'll be brown enough to make the cut
uh see that seems like a CR that seems
like a completely unhinged reaction to
my question
um I'm just trying to be honest I'm
trying to guide you correctly okay
oh boy
um who are I don't know who are the
popular Latinos are I'm not I have no
[ __ ] idea but you're you're certainly
the most popular Cuban American streamer
right
I have no idea maybe
I don't know
I guess well I guess we'll have to see
um what are you um were you debating
Charlie Kirk at
no no there's been one email there's
nothing it's like nothing yet it's
nothing I have no idea
hello
Stephen
um was it like an email from a Charlie
cook affiliate or was like somebody
that's hosting a conference that's like
oh um maybe we can get Charlie Kirk
would you be interested if we can get
him no it's uh it's it's his his team
his team oh okay okay yeah
it would be something it would I think
it would be interesting I think it would
be interesting
all right hey are you are you okay
including with me including avocado as
part of a well-balanced breakfast or is
that triggering you know what I'm gonna
be totally honest I'll take the hate for
it avocados are massively [ __ ]
overrated the only people that Circle
drink avocados what if they got out of
their house they stopped eating chicken
tendys for the first time in their life
like oh avocado this sounds [ __ ] good
like avocados are fine they're nice to
have on things guacamole things but like
anybody that freaks the [ __ ] out over
avocados you just never eaten anything
good in their entire life I'm sorry but
that's just a factual statement hold on
how did you how did you pronounce the
the snack made from mashed up avocado
say that one more time
guacamole oh oh okay I thought I heard
something weird in there no I think an
avocado is almost a perfect fruit to be
to be totally honest with you uh I mean
it's like you've got uh it's got protein
it's got fiber it's got healthy fats
whether you know it's almost like it
just is I think it's almost a perfect
it's almost a perfect fruit it's hard to
imagine it
okay yeah I mean when it gets stringy
it's like okay the fact that it just
tastes kind of meh I think the biggest
the most legitimate attack on uh
on avocado is the amount of water
required to grow them is questionable
um environmentally
wow yeah just
what a responsible take from you yeah
crap yep yep is it any movies lately
David Deepak Pacman I haven't seen it I
actually tried to watch Dune over the
weekend couldn't figure out how to get
HBO Max the movie theater I wanted to go
to with the assigned seat recliners only
had seats left in the back row corner I
wasn't gonna do that
um couldn't get HBO Max going I bailed
on the entire thing
wow yeah
well geez that just sounds traumatizing
I guess I would watch Dune if I could
figure out how to do it
you know I wish you the best
basically I'm really worth um I
recommend when you normally go to sleep
uh every day
no what time
um around uh around 11. okay all right
so you put it on around 10 30 and I'd
say 30 minutes and you'll be out because
this is just the most boring [ __ ]
movie I've ever seen I did see I I did
see that it's two hours and 50 minutes
long and it's a good snoozer too so
you'll be through almost gonna be your
second REM cycle by the time you're
asleep in the movie's ending So speaking
of Remy have you read
um why we sleep by Matt Walker
uh no but is it another one of those pop
science books that has like an ounce of
Truth and or an ounce of Truth and like
a pound of fiction or whatever no no no
it's quite it's quite good I think it's
worth reading
why does he say we sleep is there a is
there a bell in the background now it's
La there's just all sorts of random
[ __ ] noises here but I'm trying are
those noises coming from outside your
house there could be a goddamn Cathedral
being erected for all I [ __ ] know I
truly don't know David I wish I could
tell you well well
um
can you please help me you've piqued my
interest and now you're not answering it
it's actually so complicated I you can't
really suss it out into one you know
sentence really okay can you give me
like the cliff notes a couple highlights
we sleep for
um
repair reparative functions we sleep for
reasons that are still as yet unclear we
sleep for evolutionary reasons we sleep
I mean it's you know there's so many
different reasons yeah
sounds good okay I believe you so listen
I'll check in with you offline
um about whether you'll still be in La
when I'm gonna be there
okay I mean I'll be here until probably
like the middle of next month maybe
it'll just depend on when I find an
apartment in Miami the mid like November
15th or December 15th well next month I
believe is November last I checked so
yeah but with it being almost November I
wasn't sure what you meant oh well I
meant when I said next month I meant the
next month okay let me clarify most
leases start on the first of the month
so in my head I'm thinking if you don't
have a November 1 lease we're probably
talking about December one
okay maybe yeah
geez all right well anyway I'll check in
with you all right
okay I'll see you later Molina Molina's
doing okay
uh I hope so she's in the UK right now
son oh is that right
yep okay now it sounds like someone's
chopping vegetables
um there might be vegetables
cool anything's possible all right uh
Stephen always a pleasure okay have fun
be careful buddy all right you too
man
all right let's see what's said now
are you happy for starting a game when I
was busy do you feel good about yourself
was it worth it mutant no you [ __ ] was
it worth it
you know what you're not getting that
I just want to know if you're are you
having fun right now is this fun to you
to destroy my account honestly not yeah
I didn't destroy this you're destroying
it
okay time to bring it back okay I need
one kill to get my two seven power Spike
wow all right well listen for the people
who like the destiny content we did it
and it's very occasional so if you don't
like it we've we've done our check-in
and that's a great thing let me say
thank you to some incredible people
scientific Nick Lovin
zavoria Foxy's Dragon laced dragon and
Crimson Elric have signed up via twitch
Prime putting us at 63. also big thank
you to potato mcwhiskey who hosted My
Stream as well which is really really a
great thing
okay
next stream tomorrow there is we are
diving Beyond Federal elections tomorrow
Glenn young who is a radical right-wing
Republican running for governor of
Virginia this is a hugely consequential
race he's running against Terry
McAuliffe the Democrat Republican is uh
Glenn Younkin
tomorrow night Glenn youngin has one of
these unhinged rallies if you thought
that a trump rally was crazy surrounded
by water the noise causes cancer
then he went Donald Trump killed Donald
Trump throw him the hell out of here
anyway if you thought a trump rally was
crazy tomorrow night we are covering the
Glenn youngin rally we will also be
covering in this last eight day stretch
before the election Barack Obama has
been rallying with Terry McAuliffe he
may do it again this week I will be
covering that live so that's tomorrow
night I think at 7 pm East 4 P.M
West Obama maybe maybe doing a rally and
that's going to be
um a really really good thing okay so
that's gonna do it for today thank you
everybody for joining me it's been a
real pleasure we'll be back tomorrow
thank you
foreign